وكان رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هتسي
هاليفي قد قرر تشكيل فريق امني للبدء في
اجراء تحقيق في اخفاقات احداث السابع من
اكتوبر بجوانبها الامنيه والعسكريه
والاستخبارات ويضم فريق التحقيق عددا من
المسؤولين الامنيين السابقين من بينهم
وزير الامن ورئيس اركان الجيش السابق
شاؤول موفاز الذي سيكون على راس الفريق
بالاضافه الى الرئيس السابق لشعبه
الاستخبارات
العسكريه في ركش والقائد السابق لقياده
الجيش الجنوبيه سامي ترجمان وقالت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان التحقيقات ستشمل ايضا
سير العمليات العسكريه خلال الحرب على
غزه قال زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا اي
لبيد ان لدى اسرائيل شعبا قويا وجيشا
متمكنا وحكومه ضعيفه بائسه وانتقد لابي
جلسه مجلس الوزراء الاخيره ووصفها بانها
انحدار جديد غير مسبوق وقال ان وزراء
يحاولون اهانه رئيس الاركان ورئيس الوزراء
و رئيس الوزراء لا يفعل شيئا مضيفا ان هذه
ليست حكومه بل كارثه وطنيه لبيد اضاف ان
بن كفير الذي يؤيد الارهاب ولم يخدم في
الجيش يهاجم شاؤول موفاز القائد الجدير
والبطل في اسرائيل وفق
قوله ينضم الينا الان من حيفا مراسل
الجزيره احمد هزيم اهلا بك معنا تطور رات
لافته بطبيعه الحال وخلافات تطفو على
السطح وتصريحات للبيد تبدو انها قاسيه في
في تعبيرها واستخداماتها للالفاظ باتجاه
بن كفير وبنيامين
نتنياهو نعم عبد السلام هي استمرار
لايام واكثر من اسبوعين الان من ظهور
الخلافات السياسيه بين الاقطاب المختلفه
على السطح رغم ما ما يتم الحديث عنه من
وحده وطنيه ووحده صف لوجود البلاد في حاله
حرب هناك في قطاع غزه واستمرار المعركه
العسكريه اخر هذه الخلافات السياسيه ما
حدث بالامس من هجوم كان لاذعا ومشادات
بالكلام بين كل من بنفير وسموت ووزيرين
اخرين من حزب الاكود الذين اتهموا رئيس
هيئه الاركان هيرسي هاليفي بانه يعمل من
دون مشورتهم اي من دون
مشوره كنه المصغره او المجلس الوزاري
المصغر حين قام بتعيين شاول مفاز على راس
فريق التحقيق فيما حدث في السابع من
اكتوبر ورفعت الجلسه دون ان تناقش جدول
اعمالها وكان مطروحا على جدول الاعمال
موضوع او ملف اليوم التالي اضافه الى
ملفات عسكريه وامنيه اخرى ومن هنا ياتي
تاتي الانتقادات من ميني جانس ومن لابيل
وحتى الان التصريح الذي ادلى به للتو وزير
الدفاع جالانت عندما قال بانه يجب عدم
اقحام الجيش في او استخدامه بشكل غير
مسؤول لاغراض سياسيه ضيقه وهنا هو هو
الحديث في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه في
اوساط السياسيه الاسرائيليه حديث المعلقين
الاسرائيليين في وسائل الاعلام الذين
يقولون بان الائتلاف الحاكم وتحديدا
بنيامين نتنياهو وبين جفير وسموت يقدمون
اولويه المصالح السياسيه الضيقه
على مساله الحرب وهي مساله وطنيه ومساله
وحده وطنيه هنا في اسرائيل وان هذا يجب ان
يتوقف كما استمعنا لجانس وهو يقول بان هذه
يجب ان تتوقف يجب ان تكون مساله الامن
ومساله السلام هي الاولى بدل مساله
المصالح السياسيه الضيقه حتى ان البعض في
وسائل النم الاسرائيليه عبد السلام ذهبوا
ابعد من ذلك ليقول بان هذا ما قام به
سموتريش وبنك فير افتعال لمنع
المجلس الوزاري المصغر من مناقشه ملف
اليوم التالي لانهم لا يريدون ل نقاش هذا
الملف ان يتم في حضور كل من جانس وايزن كو
ويريدون من هذا الملف ان تتم مناقشته في
الائتلاف الحكومي بعيدا عن هؤلاء بعيدا عن
جناحي جانس وايزن كوف لذا بعض وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه الان بدات تقول بان
بنيامين نتنياهو وخلال الايام الما وعلى
مدى اسبوعين وفي ظل حرب مستعره يضع مصالحه
السياسيه الضيقه اولا على حساب المجهود
الحربي و تظهر الى السطح هذه الخلافه
السياسيه في حين ان المعارك جاريه في قطاع
غزه صفارات الانذار تدوي في مدن وبلدات
ومستوطنات الغلاف غلاف
غزه صفارات الانذار تدوي في الشمال كان
هناك سقوط لثلاث سقوط صاروخين وصاروخ ثالث
اطلق من جنوب لبنان تم اسقاطه عبر القبه
الحديديه قبل قليل الان قبل دقائق من الان
دو صفرات الانذار في كريات شموه في الشمال
وبينما تستعل او تشتعل هذه المعركه التي
تخوضها اسرائيل من وجه نظرهم من اجل
وجودها ومن اجل امنها واستقرارها وسلامها
هم يقولون بان هؤلاء اي سموتريتش وبنج فير
ونتنياهو يغلبون مصالحهم السياسيه الضيقه
على سير المعركه العس
وامن
اسرائيل شكرا جزيلا لك احمد هزي مراسل
الجزيره كان معنا من حيفا على كل هذه
الايضاحات